is cool about it that's pretty cool man
it's embarrassed but she was like did
you and I was like I sharted and she's
like oh my God and she like kept on
doing the laundry wow
[Music]
welcome back to another full length
awesome episode of the careful boys we
have with us today Miss Colleen
Lionheart oh
hi Mark oh hi heart so um I wanted to
know from you guys this is a little bit
of a heavier one are we currently off
the Record
we are currently off the Record there it
is hey thank you look at the camera
thank you
when was the first time
in a relationship oh we both went
oh whoa they got a secret handle yeah
they're cool
that's so cool
dancers dude and they're like leave it
in leave it in don't
edits I need it for my real please
can you chop that for us also the real
start go ahead email us later tell me
when was the first time in a
relationship that you felt truly loved
wow that's not heavy this is vulnerable
still waiting this guy here I'll start
off so that you can you know have a
little frame of reference for me
um it was my first girlfriend it was in
high school I was a freshman not as a
sophomore so I'm 15 years old I didn't
know what it was like to be in a
relationship with somebody I had no idea
what my responsibilities were
I just kind of dove in we went for it
the next day after like I asked her to
be my girlfriend she had went
um
there was a Burger King next to the
school she got to school early bought me
a Whopper meal
and gave it to me at school when I got
there
and I thought
I'm gonna marry this woman wow because
I'd never known what that was like like
she bought me the thing that I love wow
and I didn't ask for it she just went
and got so much initiative yeah it's
just a Whopper fries and a drink at at 8
A.M in the morning and I was like
this is this is my dream yeah and I was
like this is love this is what love
making polo shirt
s
so is this like love love or is this
like the where we all think we're in
love and [ __ ] I think you know if the
that one was level well the more time
that you let go by you start to like
change your definition of what it is but
this is the most rawest like
um juvenile understanding of like damn
this person loves me when David threw
those chocolates at me I felt loved wow
yeah how you doing now you said you're
single right yeah clearly not loved yeah
good so you're still waiting on it yeah
yeah still waiting on that good idiot
and as we as we warm up into this and we
keep these short you know stories going
until we get some real deep [ __ ] I will
say well we'll go with the long one with
you then no we're gonna start with hold
on hold on I was gonna give you
something great but you guys took away
my [ __ ] momentum okay you guys got to
read the room a little bit though you
know what we're gonna freeze time right
now
give all the time you want
I just lost some momentum really no you
didn't
come on just just say wait you guys
ruined it no I did it fine I'm just
saying it was a short story I was gonna
say one time like I like shark in my
shorts right and it was in the laundry
and then when she was willing to [ __ ]
wash it for me you know what I mean she
was cool about it that's pretty cool man
it's embarrassed but she was like did
you and I was like I sharted and she's
like oh my God and she like kept on
doing the laundry wow I was like yo this
[ __ ] is mine because when there's
acceptance like that yeah that's pretty
[ __ ] cool is that the one that got
away no someone is still around you I'm
saying hey let's go
she was like
you call this a shark
he's like why are you Ziploc bagging
your [ __ ]
you put it in a Ziploc why did you do
that
first of all it's Costco it's not a
Ziploc don't put that in with mine God
don't put that in I'll put these in with
their whites
AKA off-whites
you call that a shark I just love that
that's funny anybody have any other
memories of the first time they were
like okay this person really loves okay
I'll tell you I'll tell you I I thought
about this when you said this I was like
whoa that's that's true I did I do
remember being like whoa I'm like an
adult
and like we love each other you know but
it was um so my like first serious
girlfriend and I like we used I used to
like go to go to high school and then
come home I was like a freshman
sophomore and like we'd go to her house
and like her mom is like super chill and
like all the stuff and then like her mom
would always have to go pick up her like
her younger brother from like Middle
School we're in high school so like
Middle School's whack anyway so I'm glad
that we don't have to even be there when
the middle school is being picked up so
nobody even sees us right and then her
mom would leave but her mom was always
big like like like you know if we were
even watching a movie together or
anything and she's like she's like let
me see your hands
okay yeah we're good yeah no diddlings
happening oh dude oh it's you know by
the way it's so hard to let go of a [ __ ]
and raise your hand like oh no it's so
hard to [ __ ] oh dude I put my hands
up like it wasn't holding a penis like
30 seconds ago I was Meanwhile your toes
in her vagina yeah dude bro no I'm like
[ __ ] four bangers in and I'm like I'm
I'm like oh
show the viscosity
like that that should be good I don't
wet your hands out you have to keep it
at light level whatever yeah if you if
you start to tilt or deviate then
there's the shine and that would be a
nightmare scenario never happened to me
though so it's like oh hands sure guess
what we're finger banging and we're anal
banging all day
That's A Shard all day
I'm four bangers here one two three four
and look at that hand the front and the
back well my whole thing was you better
be able to take four if you want to
handle me dog
no so so in this situation you start to
realize you're attracted to my pinkies
and then these little guyses as small as
I can possibly get them no no
um but no so then four Beggars teeth
four fingers too no no so then uh I
would be it would be like hey I'm gonna
go pick up
we'll call him Bradley we'll call him
Bradley I'm gonna go pick up Bradley by
the way that was his real name
let me think of another name
I thought the lights the lights are
bright dude I got nervous it's been a
while since you did improv
so then I just go with the real shoot
I'm not kidding like it's like watching
uh the door close it's like as soon as
the door closes close come off pants go
down and then like my girlfriend at the
time is like blowing me and I'm like
doing stuff to her badge that I think is
kind of weird and like we're both doing
this to each other like instant like I'm
saying like it hasn't even been like
three milliseconds
like people people don't really know how
fast that like a teenager can get their
clothes off because they just don't
think about it like that like they think
that they'll be some nervous [ __ ] we
got through that [ __ ] months ago I'm at
my chick's mom's house like it's time to
throw down so like so like that's what
would happen as soon as she left to pick
up Bradley
but that is his name
we're dick we were [ __ ] naked bro
naked and then that's when the real fun
began but like people don't so then so
then there was a okay there was a moment
I'll never forget it was like my first
encounter I believe with with love where
I looked at her and she was completely
naked
and this is [ __ ] made stuff I'm sorry
to admit this but I actually got choked
up because because she felt a little bit
insecure and I was just like you're
[ __ ] beautiful wow
and it and it was like that but you felt
loved from that from her I felt love I
felt loved from what she was doing to my
penis at the time I see but no but no no
honestly like she hadn't she wasn't even
she was like three feet from me but it
was like this moment you're still in her
we're both hey we were both like naked
looking at each other and it's like the
most vulnerable I've ever been at that
point it was like this moment of like I
love you I love everything I'm looking
at I love you and it was like really it
felt really real and then you might
never been like completely naked with
someone else that vulnerable before is
that why yeah yeah it was my first time
ever I was like 14 or some shots yes wow
and then
when I was watching X-Men 2 X-Men United
with her while Wolverine is in the
mansion
Striker dude that's when I had sex for
the first time that's when I lost my
Virginia I'm not kidding
X-Men two to a packed house
that's a real story I lost your
virginity to a pack up in the theater to
[ __ ] Logan
you Legend thank you during the mansions
yeah okay
whoa Steve's like
that's how good the scene was nobody
noticed great scene every eyes glued to
the [ __ ] screen Brian's singer great
director
do you have to say that does everyone
say that why are you laughing why are
you laughing that's a great director
thank you yeah you're welcome so that's
it that's what I thought I honestly I
know well I did some bits around it but
all of it was true but I really in that
moment felt I think real love for the
first time and thought it was possible
to feel such a way wow that was about
that yeah that's kind of hard to top
really good thank you
very good hey I'm glad we could put our
swords down and just agree on that so uh
having heard that did that trigger any
memories in your guys lives that were
similar
yeah
in my adult life yeah
um
the the most I think like wow moment was
um so when me and Joe were doing JK
this is we started in 2007 and just kind
of from the start you kind of have like
this whole like you know like Asian
guilt thing like I'm I'm not [ __ ]
doing what my parents want me to do I'm
supposed to go to college and do all
this [ __ ] but then you have this passion
towards them that you really enjoy doing
especially with the best friend at the
time so we're always doing it and then
we want to like
grow and get it to a point but then
YouTube this is like 2007 2008 2009
no there's no successful YouTubers you
know what I mean like everyone is on
their path to go in there
so like it was something where like me
and Joe keep talking about like we have
so much fun but we [ __ ] make a
thousand bucks every six months
very much so like what the [ __ ] are we
gonna do
and then so that was something that was
always on my mind we took me and Jill
talk about it so like we were like okay
what if we started looking up jobs that
are like uh that have like the 3x12
schedule you know like cops nurses that
kind of stuff or like okay cool then
we'll just we work three days a week
being out a real job get a salary should
be a cup nurse yeah a nurse they'll have
like four four days to write and [ __ ]
do whatever right and um and I I think
Geo can tell that this was like such a
burden on my mind because I was about to
graduate soon too oh so I'm like as soon
as I graduate either I get a real job or
I go to graduate school or something but
my heart's in JK what the [ __ ] am I
gonna do and that's something that me
and Joe just always talk about and we've
already taken a break one time from JK
because we're like oh we're just [ __ ]
around what are we doing wasting our
lives away
but then we came back around and did it
again because we really just really
enjoyed it
and then I remember sitting and Geo's
renting a room at her like friend's
house and I remember uh sitting on the
counter like I was just like [ __ ] I
don't know what to do and then she goes
and she was a corporate woman at the
time ready and she was like how about
you pursue JK
and I'll just support you and I was like
what the [ __ ] no one has ever [ __ ]
I'm like you're gonna [ __ ] support me
while I'm [ __ ] doing something at
zero guaranteed future I'm just putting
on these [ __ ] Uncle Sam hats and
[ __ ] talking in Vietnamese accents
and [ __ ] I'm like what the [ __ ] and I
think for the first time like for anyone
to even say that besides your parents
that's dope yeah I was like oh [ __ ] you
we'll have separate personal bank
accounts
later though like after I'm successful
obviously
like after it really works out then I
want my own money [ __ ] I want my own
[ __ ] money [ __ ]
if you missed that video earlier because
I don't know what the [ __ ] order
then that doesn't work for you but I
don't [ __ ] know I I gotta pick up 40
I'm not supposed to think about that
kind of [ __ ]
but yeah that was the first time like in
my grown adult life where I was like
holy [ __ ] I think that's what love is
meant to be where it's like Full
Sacrifice I love you for who you are you
do your thing and I will do whatever I
can in my means to support you I love
that that's bad that's tight actually
that's way tight that's a really cool
story and did she I mean how long was
that but she had to do that for before
like it was sustainable
um she didn't have to do that because I
think like as a dude when you hear [ __ ]
like that it [ __ ] just charges you up
like 10 times more yeah so knowing that
you have that thing to lean on I was
like there's no no way we're ever even
gonna let it get to that point and then
she goes on that night she looks at her
mom she's like it worked Mama the trick
where you tell your man that I'm gonna
[ __ ] support you that got his ass on
fire it's testosterone through the roof
yeah I was like how about I Peg You
Until You Learn to come on your own
quickly
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] that's genius
that's what BART was explaining away I'm
like
I got nothing to Sentimental to share in
this room this one's dangerous
what about you you've been with your
wife for the whole time I'm trying to
really think like I'm trying to like dig
deep in the archives there hasn't been
like one moment you're like [ __ ] she's
been with you the entire time I know
that itself is but Nick hasn't even
dropped the L bomb yet yeah I haven't
told her I loved it
when we got married they're like you may
kiss the bride and I was like I'll spot
you're like this I'll skip this one I
think thank you yeah it is kind of hard
to really because I'm really trying to
Rack my brain of like a moment where I
really felt like loved and I was and
actually while I was thinking I was like
I do have a weird thing about like
accepting Love sometimes like I do feel
like uh I can tell [ __ ] you dude [ __ ]
you
[ __ ] you man [ __ ] you [ __ ] you you're
like my father
you're like those [ __ ] Dobermans on
Dog Whisperer that they try to pet yeah
yeah
doctor would be nice to me it's like
layering on the [ __ ] icing no I but I
really
it's like it's
um the fact that she did stick around I
guess because I felt like I always was
like
yeah yeah I got you
um yeah so I because we just grew up
together for so long and there was
always like Milestones that we just hit
together it was usually her doing it
first and then be kind of following
afterwards
um but like
yeah it's it's for some for some weird
reason I can't really think of a time or
a moment where I really felt like
um like man I feel that love courses
through my veins is usually
usually the one
I think he's still skeptical I'm still
not really buying the campaign's still
ongoing I'm not what about those moments
when you like right after you bust a nut
and then suddenly you're filled with
emotions and rationale yeah yeah yeah
even no no not even is this posting on
Clarity even when I bust a nut by myself
or you know with my wife it's I I feel
normal plexiglass yeah yeah yeah well
little kids ride by their books
mom's standing up on my window
that's a joke I don't do that
that's really again we don't have to
order leave this part in please probably
probably that video will come out next
November so whatever
yeah I just did the reference I'll be
adults by then
uh yeah like it's uh it is weird I don't
know how to answer this honestly and
this is a heavy one yeah you [ __ ]
sprung this up on me you're holding back
and they don't no I swear I'm not
holding back it's just a matter of like
we've just been through so much together
and one of the main reasons I what I
thought about was like her willingness
to be able to like uh deal with my
[ __ ] really it's just her sticking
around and being there for me and and
being like her unconditional yeah like
accepting me for who I am because like
I'm definitely not an easy person to be
in a relationship with by any means
um and a lot of the stuff that has come
with being a relationship with me has
been like really hard on her in a lot of
ways so
I never felt like there was like
judgment I never felt like
she you know
because I guess in certain relationships
there are there is like a hierarchy of
like a little more dominant or not and
I've just never felt like there was any
of that we were just always a team and
she was just always had my back like
she's a writer you know I mean no matter
kind of like what BART said like it's
just like I know that I she got my back
like and nothing else is is ever gonna
like uh top that feeling yeah you know
right right baby writer's right you know
what I mean but yeah that's pretty much
it
hey Nick don't ask me that [ __ ]
question again
or what Nick you're getting knocked out
I will knock you that's an amazing place
I'll start talking about [ __ ] [ __ ]
Japan you want me to do that you know
Japan yeah Japan dude and I'll start
playing on the [ __ ] harmonica
and then I love you man uh hey [ __ ] you
I love you
I'm [ __ ] almost at you get off me man
it's your turn Anthony give me the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you you
you know what I will say though that um
I think from from the stuff that you do
Express even though it's like
incrementally uh
shared in small parts I think through
what you say I have learned and
recognized in my own path times where I
may have overshot because you've
maintained the correct resonance in a
relationship that I think I've always
wanted but always
went too hard or not given enough for so
I will say even though you [ __ ]
barely say anything when you do when you
do it's just the plain truth that Trump
someone that just [ __ ] talks for two
hours and doesn't really give you
anything of words
[Laughter]
I appreciate that right thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign